qu'est-ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras grande Carole danseuse et Sainte
Vierge danseuse oui et Sainte Vierge
pour être pr du
Jésus qui c'est Jésus
Jésus petit bébé et qu'est-ce qui lui
est arrivé à Jésus il des méchant il mis
des clous dans la tête il on mis des
clous dans la
tête et alors la Sainte Vierge c'était
sa copine non sa maman ah bon et toi tu
vux être Sainte Vierge et danseuse et
oui c'est pas très compatible d'après ce
que je sais dans notre métier tu fais ta
prière le soir
non tu vas à l'église
non comment tu fais ton signe de croix
vas-y
montre-moi fa comme oui
vas-y au nom du Père au nom du Père du
Fils du Saint-Esprit soitil petit Jésus